bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans notre
huitième live tv samsung ce live qui est
préparé organisé et présenté par des
personnes de Samsung donc des personnes
passionnées de l'univers de la télé mais
pas que et cette émission est bien
évidemment live sur l'ensemble de nos
réseaux Samsung YouTube
Twitter et Facebook voilà bienvenue
parmi nous comme je le disais c'est
notre huitième live c'est le dernier
live de l'année c'est la fin de la
première saison de nos émissions presque
mensuelles et on a commencé en mars 2022
et on a décidé qu'on a commencé à faire
ses lives d'inviter
un créateur de contenu un journaliste ou
un influenceur quelqu'un de passionné
aussi ou d'expert dans dans le milieu de
la télé et on a commencé justement nos
live avec Monsieur Greux qui est un
créateur de contenu voilà très important
voilà
bah c'est lui qui nous a accompagné pour
ce premier live et je trouvais que
c'était important pour terminé cette
première saison de le réinviter à
nouveau pour qu'il puisse nous parler de
son expérience nous parler de ce qu'il
avait vécu en 2022 et de faire un peu
une rétrospective de l'ensemble de nos
lives et de fois quel produit vous avez
le plus intéressant donc je suis très
content aujourd'hui de t'accueillir
monsieur après 8 mois bah ouais c'est
génial parce qu'en plus on s'invite la
mutuellement parce que en fait je
t'invite sur ma chaîne youtube tu
m'invites sur vos réseaux comme ça c'est
une invitation mutuelle puis c'est
ambiance de Noël c'est chaleureux c'est
sympa il y a le sapin tout va bien et
c'est pour ça que nous avons tous donc
des pulls à l'effigie de Noël voilà vous
verrez que tout le monde va passer la
commande va pouvoir donc voilà c'est pas
c'est fait exprès voilà de bel effet
voilà donc on est aussi en live sur tes
chaînes sur ta chaîne Youtube exactement
on a d'ailleurs le chat devant nous
voilà donc surtout n'hésitez pas à
donner vos avis ou avoir des
commentaires nous y répondrons avec
Monsieur gros exactement donc ils sont
là on va porter les yeux dessus on va
dire il y a beaucoup de monde à David
Lucas Dylan bonjour à tout le monde
soyez les bienvenus voilà donc pendant
ce live qui va durer je sais pas le
temps qu'il faut le temps
pour partager l'ensemble de nos nos
coups de coeur puisque en fait c'est
l'émission de Nola de Noël et on a cinq
coups de cœur en fait qu'on voudrait
partager avec toi et sur lequel on
voudrait avoir ton avis mais plus un
avis comme au début on commençait à se
connaître on était un peu dans pas dans
la séduction mais voilà il fallait qu'on
dise du bien etc on se draguer on se
draguer là on sera plus voilà c'est
comme tu l'as dit on tu nous accueilles
et on t'accueille mais aussi en
parallèle on s'est vu plusieurs fois
cette année parce que tu traverses un
peu l'Europe où tu traverses l'ensemble
de l'actualité électronique grand public
donc dans la grande maison Samsung on se
voit souvent donc voilà maintenant faut
vraiment dire la vérité et puis il faut
que tu nous commandes nos cinq coups de
cœur donc je vais juste vous les nommer
parce que cinq personnes vont aussi nous
accompagner pendant ce sur ce plateau
donc le premier on va parler du
freestyle alors pourquoi le freestyle
parce qu'on a décidé pour Noël justement
de faire quelque chose de particulier
c'est génial de faire gagner un
freestyle d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu mais sur Twitter il y a
quelques jours je vous ai alors annoncé
effectivement le live et en plus de ça
et bien je vous ai posé une question
savoir quel était votre TV préféré chez
Samsung et donc il y a eu un tirage au
sort et on dévoilera à la fin quel est
le nom de la personne qui gagne the
freestyle ça c'est chouette et donc le
freestyle je sais pas si tout le monde
connaît sans spoiler le reste mais on
peut quand même voir que je vais le
sortir et remettre mais c'est pas
produit c'est ça le freestyle ouais
c'est ça freestyle donc quelqu'un
d'entre vous ou dans ta communauté a
gagné ce produit là je vais le refermer
parce que je vais laisser bien
évidemment Lorraine en parler mais avant
ça ça c'est notre premier coup de cœur
tu vas nous en parler après deuxième
coup de cœur qui est important c'est le
frame il connaît le frame c'est quand ce
téléviseur devient un tableau quand on
confond un écran noir a justement un
tableau ça il faut qu'on en reparle
parce qu'on a une innovation
technologique extraordinaire troisième
point c'est le LED
ou chez nous QDO LED mais en fait l'olen
on a lancé cette année LED avec la Coupe
du Monde et le Black Friday voilà il y a
eu il y a eu quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans le marché notamment pour
Samsung voilà quatrième point c'est la
Smart donc la télé connectée ça va être
coup de cœur aussi on va être le
présenter pourquoi parce que on a une
nouvelle interface pas que Entertainment
mais aussi gaming ça c'est génial ça toi
et le dernier évidemment une télé
s'embar de son c'est pas vraiment un
écosystème qui marche à fond on a une
technologie dans le barre de son qui
font exploser ensemble donc on va te le
présenter aussi mini mini moi je suis
halluciné quand je suis venu parce que
je sais pas si vous voyez sur le côté on
a ce tout petit truc là la barre de son
c'est je l'avais jamais vu elle est
tellement ministre incroyable donc j'ai
hâte que tout le monde dise plus et ça
c'est la cinquième coup de cœur donc
voilà comme s'il est très intéressé tout
le monde va nous suivre jusqu'à la fin
donc j'ai le plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir d'accord Lorraine qui est
justement notre chef de groupe sur la
partie lifestyle donc nos produits un
peu hors télé salut Lorraine
comment ça va écoutez je suis ravie
d'être là pour ce dernier de l'année ce
live de Noël et magnifique pull avec
vous
de Samsung
pourquoi parce qu'on a lancé cette année
c'est notre premier vidéoprojecteur
qu'on a qu'on a lancé sur le marché
projecteur nomades ce qu'on avait déjà
the première qui était notre projecteur
vraiment orienté cinéma avec une qualité
d'image en 4K là on est sur un
projecteur beaucoup plus nomade je le
reprends je vais l'ouvrir donc c'est ça
freestyle donc the freestyle donc le
plus intéressé en fait c'est c'est
l'objectif de cela c'est d'avoir les
commentaires de Mr Greg sur chacun
monsieur d'Aurélien hop mais en fait le
freestyle
au lancement j'étais venu au lancement
je l'ai vu avant le lancement et ça
c'est très cool c'est ça où on a des
fois des supers opportunités c'est de
pouvoir voir les produits avant même
qu'ils soient annoncés sur le marché et
le freestyle je l'ai découvert il y a un
peu plus d'un an alors que vous l'avez
lancé en janvier janvier tout à fait
mais on avait fait un peu de
d'un petit buzz à avant avec une
présentation du coup à certains
privilégiés alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le freestyle donc c'est
un vidéo au projecteur extrêmement léger
puisqu'il fait seulement 800 g
extrêmement nomade donc tu peux l'amener
là par exemple je sais pas si tu pars en
vacances à Noël mais tu vas pouvoir
l'amener partout souvent
dans les petits chats les l'ambiance est
super mais les télés elles sont beaucoup
moins sympas là je peux du coup projeter
mon contenu facilement sur un mur ou
alors tout simplement sur un plafond
avec donc une qualité d'image en Full HD
jusqu'à 110 pouces donc c'est un écran
vraiment géant à disposition et ce qui
est très important c'est que il va faire
les réglages tout seul donc c'est à dire
que tu as pas besoin de t'embêter tu vas
pouvoir hop l'orienter vers ton mur et
même si tu n'es pas tout à fait droit il
va ajuster les trapèzes l'autofocus etc
donc pour toi en fait c'est hyper simple
tu as juste à le poser et à profiter de
tous tes contenus puisque bien sûr il y
a la Smart télé qui est intégré à
l'intérieur donc tu as Netflix tu as
Prime vidéo tu as RMC tu as toutes tes
applications que tu pourrais retrouver
sur tes autres téléviseurs directement
dans ce petit objet qui est super et tu
vois hop on a un petit étui dédié pour
pouvoir le ranger le protéger et
l'amener partout donc c'est à dire que
quel que soit le mur ou surtout sur
lequel tu veux le projeter il fait
l'auto calibration et l'autofocus
automatique ça c'est plutôt pas mal si
tu n'es pas tout à fait en face du mur
même
si la surface n'est pas tout à fait
plane et même si ton mur par exemple
n'est pas tout à fait blanc
donc il descend quand même Mr Grey
manipuler ce beau produit parce que
comme tu l'as dit les Smart donc c'est à
dire que ça Netflix tu as tout à disney+
dessus tu emmènes tes enfants tu les
mets dans une pièce enfin n'importe où
aujourd'hui regarde leur programme ou il
se reconnecte sur leur compte quoi je
peux lui mettre un petit film de Noël
très facilement quoi tout à fait tout à
fait non mais ça ça va en plus le truc
est vraiment surprenant parce que tu le
vois tu dis bon ok je sais pas combien
ça pèse c'est léger hein
il est léger tu as de l'USB c'est de
côté alors tu peux le micro je vois tu
as un petit switch commutateur là pour
activer désactiver le micro
c'est super il est super et on a aussi
on l'a pas amené aujourd'hui mais on a
une petite batterie qui est en
accessoire il peut acheter également
parce ici tu es en extérieur ou si à ton
domicile ou tu es en vacances il n'y a
pas de prise à proximité hop tu viens
mettre ta batterie juste dessous et tu
peux profiter jusqu'à 3h de contenu avec
ta batterie
par exemple et d'aller projeter quelque
part je peux ma batterie nomade et j'en
vois quoi en USB C tu peux projeter le
contenu que tu veux mais tu peux aussi
jouer avec une console de jeux ou tu
peux aussi avoir ton téléphone portable
et puis projeter tes affaires et jouer
tes photos tout ce que tu veux c'est à
la fois génial en termes d'expérience
puisque on a je te dis et 110 pouces un
écran géant donc toutes tes films tout
est séries mais c'est aussi génial parce
que tu peux l'emmener partout et
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les personnes
qui vont acheter il utilise autant à
domicile que en déplacement donc c'est
vraiment un produit multi-usage et ultra
à côté donc c'est notre coup de coeur
cette année chez Samsung je pense pour
beaucoup de personnes dans l'équipe
c'est c'est un superbe coup de cœur et
bah qui a qui marche aussi très bien
donc c'est ce produit là elle sera
offert une personne de voilà on va
gagner avec son petit KACE pour
l'emmener où il veut ça c'est cool et il
me semble vous dira à la fin de
l'émission le nom on mettra sur un petit
bandeau je pense c'est ça vous saurez ça
et vous verrez voilà donc merci donc ça
c'est notre premier coup de cœur ce
qu'on a des questions de la communauté
alors on peut tout à fait le connecter
par exemple avec une barre de son en
Bluetooth ou en wi-fi ok pratique
c'est vrai que j'ai oublié de le
préciser tout à fait donc il y a un son
quand même à 360 intégré on le voit ici
et haut-parleurs tout autour mais si on
veut un vrai son home cinéma on va
pouvoir venir le brancher à une enceinte
ou à une barre de son il demande quel
est justement la puissance de du
haut-parleur 5 watts 5 watts donc ça
reste
c'est bien si on est dans sa chambre
qu'on veut regarder un film
tranquillement on va bien entendre le
film mais c'est vrai si on veut ce qu'on
a un grand écran bénéficié de la
meilleure expérience cinéma avec du
Dolby Atmos là encore va mieux falloir
s'équiper dans une barre de son ou d'une
enceinte supplémentaire on nous demande
du HDMI il n'y a pas de HDMI sur
celui-là alors en fait on va avoir on va
pouvoir brancher un adaptateur ici au
micro HDMI micro
HDMI oui Olivier qui donne la réponse
exactement
sur ta chaîne parce que on pouvait pas
gagner le produit non j'aurais reconnu
ton pseudo j'aurais dit non je te redis
pas toi ok merci Lorraine donc ce sera
pas celui-ci hein qu'on va offrir ce
sera voilà tout beau tout notre journée
très très cool merci Lorraine il y a une
deuxième notre deuxième coup de cœur
c'est un peu notre coup de cœur à tous
parce que dans le marché de la télé qui
a marché hyper dynamique qui a un marché
wahou on a réussi quand même à mettre
sur le marché un téléviseur qui devient
un tableau et en fait les personnes ont
plutôt l'intérêt pour le tableau et
après ils ont les fait waouh de se dire
[ __ ] mais c'est une télé parce qu'on
est arrivé à avoir un écran qui est
tellement ressemblant à un tableau quel
que soit l'oeuvre une photo ou une
peinture finalement on a les fait waouh
magnifiquement posé sur un pied studio
rotatif on va vous faire la petite démo
après donc ça c'est un accessoire mais
offre comme tu l'as dit bon moi c'est
mon coup de cœur Guillaume tu le sais
c'est mon premier produit que j'ai lancé
quand je suis arrivée chez Samsung donc
j'ai une affection particulière pour the
frame mais je suis pas la seule c'est je
pense le produit que beaucoup de
personnes ont même chez Samsung on le
voit ici c'est un magnifique tableau
il réunit tous téléviseur je dirais
parce qu'il réunit à la fois une superbe
expérience avec une qualité d'image on
est sur du Q LED 4K la nouveauté de
cette année un magnifique écran mat on a
plus du tout de reflets à la fois qu'on
regarde l'écran ou même encore en mode
tableau c'est encore plus bluffant parce
qu'on a vraiment l'impression que ça va
étape tableau et je vous fais ma petite
démo si j'approche le flash enfin je
passe de mon smartphone hop devant on le
voit pas pas du tout la lumière est
entièrement dissipée
alors vous vous le voyez pas parce que
là tellement d'éclairage c'est fou on
peut voir un point légèrement plus
lumineux là sur le côté mais il y a pas
de reflet donc le truc est fou et ça
c'est un truc moi j'adore quand je vais
tester différentes télé c'est vrai qu'il
y a une spécificité sur les dalles de
Samsung et Dalmat c'est qu'effectivement
on a vraiment quasiment pas de réflexion
et quel que soit l'angle moi j'ai une
grande baie vitrée chez moi je me mets
sur le côté je suis peinard et ça c'est
une vraie innovation ce qu'on avait du
coup cette année sur la gamme de the
frame puisque même en termes de confort
visuel on a des études qui ont prouvé
que c'est beaucoup moins fatigant pour
l'oeil de ne pas avoir de reflet donc
voilà je le disais une superbe
expérience télé puisqu'on a aussi un son
en Dolby Atmos et bien sûr toute la
Smart télé dont Marie va vous parler
mais c'est bien plus que ça en fait
c'est bien plus qu'un superbe téléviseur
c'est aussi un objet magnifique un
véritable tableau qu'on a dans son
intérieur on le voit ici avec une
peinture magnifique donc on est resté
dans le thème un petit peu de Noël mais
on a donc plus de 2000 oeuvres
disponibles sur the frame je sais pas si
tu le savais avec notre fameux hardcore
sur lequel on va pouvoir venir s'abonner
donc c'est 4,99 € par mois ou 49,99 € à
l'année et on va avoir accès à plus de
1000 oeuvres de partenaires extrêmement
prestigieux puisque on a le musée du
Louvre par exemple yellow corner le Tate
Museum ou le musée
ermitage ce qui est bien c'est que
justement maintenant l'interface fait
que tu as des playlists un petit peu en
fonction des thèmes de la saison etc
pour ça que là il était poussé quand tu
vas sur la store du frame beaucoup
d'images ou de photos ou de peinture qui
sont liées justement à la saison de Noël
à la neige au Père Noël etc et puis
après le Printemps et donc c'est quand
même très très sympa qu'on se rend
compte que quand on expose une oeuvre on
la change entre 5 et 7 fois par semaine
vient presque un diaporama donc en fait
les gens s'habituent à faire tourner en
fait le tableau qu'ils ont chez eux
c'est génial c'est super joli et donc là
on présente aujourd'hui sur ce pied
studio rotatif on va vous montrer juste
après mais il faut savoir que
l'accroche murale est fournie en fait
avec le téléviseur ça souvent les
personnes ne le savent pas parce que
c'est pas le cas avec les autres
téléviseurs là on a l'accroche qui
fournit ou tout simplement des pieds
standards si on le souhaite le poser sur
un meuble comme un téléviseur un petit
peu plus classique et autres avantages
d'un zofren c'est qu'on peut je me lève
le personnaliser entièrement puisque
voilà on a les cadres personnalisables
donc là on a choisi couleur teck mais on
a d'autres coloris donc on a blanc on a
couleur noyé on a aussi couleur
terracotta voilà on a plusieurs choix
disponibles pour pouvoir l'adapter à sa
déco à son intérieur
trop malin et toutes les tailles
justement ont un cadre c'est génial et
dans l'intégration dernière chose je
vous dis c'est aussi qu'on a la
connexion invisible je sais pas si tu
connais cette innovation la connexion
avec visible
tu l'avais quand tu as testé le 8k la
première fois ouais donc tu l'avais
connecté comment à ton
exactement
fin de 5 mètres qui est relié quasiment
pas parce que visible
ça c'est également on est les seuls à le
faire aujourd'hui et c'est une vraie
véritable valeur ajoutée puisque on a
souvent des appareils encombrants qui
viennent s'agglutiner autour du
téléviseur et là on va pouvoir tout
déporter via ce boîtier allez je vous
fais ma petite démo quand même parce que
allez tu fais tourner la télé en fait il
y a des œuvres horizontales et verticale
d'accord par exemple la Joconde
verticale horizontale donc même si on la
repars et tout vous le voyez tout cela
voilà avec la télécommande et une
accroche murale enfin un adaptateur sur
notre accroche mural ça nous permet de
modifier l'orientation du téléviseur
donc de l'oeuvre et donc de passer d'un
format horizontal et là verticale alors
il se reparamètre automatiquement mais
là c'est une œuvre qui est horizontale
aux paramétré en vertical pardon on a
aussi des adverticales là c'est plutôt
pas mal ça se passe comment du coup tu
as ta taille dans le une catalogue
d'offres verticales que tu vas pouvoir
mettre quand tu as la verticale comment
ça en fait tu as plusieurs
œuvres donc tu as une catégorie dédiée
d'oeuvres verticales et tu vas pouvoir
les choisir donc là le problème c'est
que je suis les cadeaux devant donc ça
bloque un petit peu mais voilà je vais
te montrer
je suis hyper chaud là les plus récentes
alors donc maintenant avec ça on
développe de plus en plus la catégorie
justement verticale pour pouvoir allier
les deux parce que voilà il y a plutôt
de nouvelles photos donc tu vois là tu
es vraiment sur une une série liée à
Noël à la neige et donc c'est plutôt pas
mal ce que moi je t'ai coupé ce que je
trouve en plus génial c'est que tu vois
pour venir commander aujourd'hui que les
les consommations de contenu évoluent
donc tu as plein de personnes qui vont
regarder comme tout de suite du contenu
sur un live ce format format P porte
paysage et tu veux passer en portrait je
pense notamment à des réseaux comme Tik
Tok comme les shorts YouTube et
compagnie bah là tu as le format qui est
adapté et ce qui est génial c'est que tu
es pas obligé de prendre ton smartphone
pivoter tu peux le faire sur une télé et
le pivote d'elle-même donc le truc est
quand même vachement cool
dédié pour ça dans notre catégorie
liftel tu le connais c'est le sirop
c'est notre téléviseur qui justement a
et rotatif par rapport avec ton
téléphone exactement
mais il a pas été sélectionné comme
produit
ok c'est rotatif
à Noël c'est pour moi ça fait plaisir
donc oui il y a des commentaires disons
la Joconde en fond d'écran ce serait top
oui tout à fait c'est top parce que
quand tu vas tu es venu tu es venu au
Louvre démonstration là et tout le monde
tout le monde a dit bah en fait quand on
voit notre souvenir de la Joconde c'est
toujours après dans une file d'attente
et c'est toujours énormément de monde
autour de nous et on nous dit
dépêchez-vous on se fait presque on est
pressé justement de regarder et avoir la
Joconde chez soi et se faire surprendre
qu'il nous regarde tout le temps ou
qu'on soit et tout seul avec c'est même
dérangeant ce qu'il disait d'avoir là je
compte dans le salon mais c'est vrai que
c'était fou parce que quand vous avez
fait cet événement au Louvre alors on
était hyper privilégié ça c'était génial
il y a on a été effectivement au Louvre
on a pu voir la Joconde on était pas
nombreux trois quatre dans la pièce
c'était dingue et après on la retrouvait
directement sur le sur le téléviseur et
c'était une expérience absolument
incroyable petit souci de comment il
s'appelait c'était bon Aldi non il y
avait pas aussi c'est quoi ça marche pas
qu'il y a ton capteur c'est moi qui suis
devant en fait je fais je fais homme
écran j'empêche de fonctionner
[Musique]
interférences sur le plateau c'était la
deuxième coup de coeur et maintenant on
a un troisième coup de coeur je te l'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est vraiment une
nouveauté nouveauté technologique qu'on
a lancé en 2023 c'est notre OLED
tu te vois déjà
on va on va continuer d'avancer on va
avancer très vite dans le futur déjà
donc on a lancé en 2022 notre première
gamme OLED ou plutôt que des OLED et
pour nous en parler je vais inviter
justement
Kévin merci Lorraine merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]
et on a des petites interférences aussi
mais il y a pas de souci je vous en
parler on va revenir sur ce que c'est
que l'OLED d'ailleurs pour que tout le
monde comprenne un petit peu ce que
c'est et sur ce modèle qu'on a lancé en
mars avril de cette année 2022 et ce qui
s'est passé sur la fin d'année tu en as
parlé un petit peu tout à l'heure
Guillaume donc simplement pour refaire
un petit peu l'histoire peut-être de
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'ode en fait
c'est une façon de d'afficher l'image
sur un téléviseur qui vient des pixels
et en fait le haut vient de organique
puisque les pixels sont organiques et
auto-emissifs donc en fait ça veut dire
que chacun des pixels produit sa propre
lumière
donc ça a des avantages ça aussi
quelques inconvénients historiquement
les avantages que ça peut avoir c'est
qu'on peut avoir plus de détails sur les
contrastes et sur les Noirs quand en
revanche il y a un petit peu moins de
luminosité en fait il y a pas d'effet
DALO puisque comme chaque pixel est
auto-hémisif il s'allume il génère sa
propre enfin tu sais mieux que moi sa
propre lumière donc en fait quand c'est
noir c'est full noir et quand c'est
éteint
et donc tu as pas d'effet DALO comme en
photo donc tu as plutôt voilà une très
belle image pour le cinéma totalement
effectivement il y a un vrai avantage
sur le cinéma sur les contrastes sur les
Noirs la profondeur des noirs donc il y
a un effet de profondeur sur sur l'image
mais en fait Samsung on sait pas
contenter de lancer de OLED on a voulu
on veut toujours apporter un peu plus
c'est ce que tu m'apprends aussi
Guillaume on veut toujours un petit peu
faire plus donc effectivement on est
allé rajouter ce qu'on a ce qu'on
appelle les quantum d'hôtes et c'est
pour ça qu'on parle pas seulement d'un
OLED mais d'un qd OLED donc le Q pour
quantum dot donc en fait il y a une
école quand une date en fait c'est des
nano cristaux des nanoparticules qui
s'excitent quand on passe de la lumière
et qui permettent de faire plus de
couleurs et plus de luminosité donc en
fait anciennement il y avait un petit
peu moins de lumière sur le LED et
maintenant avec du QDO LED et avec cette
couche de Quantum d'Hot on a plus de
pics de luminosité et donc plus de
couleurs et donc c'est pour ça aussi que
on l'a fait tester par par la presse
beaucoup beaucoup de bons retours
puisque on a eu beaucoup de fois l'olyde
le plus lumineux du marché donc c'est
que un ce sont c'est nous qui produisons
ben oui donc eu des LED d'accord donc
nous sommes Samsung display exactement
Samsung display qui fabrique et c'est
vraiment une nouvelle technologie
puisqu'on associe notre savoir-faire du
cudio LED puisque c'est là où on a nos
mini LED dans toute notre gamme c'est ce
qu'on fait avec la technologie
auto-hémissif de
donc ça c'est ça a été un carton ça a
été un carton plein donc on a on a lancé
mars et on a vraiment lancé en septembre
ouais si je peux me permettre ok voilà
on a le temps que vous vous le voyez le
tester etc puis on a eu 5 étoiles un peu
partout voilà on a eu des tests sur la
techno du produit en septembre on l'a
vraiment lancé notamment avec tous les
événements sportifs qu'on a connus voilà
et malheureusement avec ce qui est
arrivé samedi dernier mais au moins on
l'a lancé la Coupe du monde le Black
Friday c'était un succès un carton et on
avait seulement deux références voilà on
a pris un cinquième du marché quoi c'est
énorme c'est énorme mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est belle cette télé elle est
extrêmement fine ça me bluff et ça c'est
aussi un des avantages du quantum
d'hôtes c'est qu'on vient enlever un
filtre qui en plus sur l'olive classique
OK et ce qui fait que le téléviseur est
ultra fin en fait il fait moins de 4 mm
d'épaisseur en haut donc c'est presque
aussi fin avec une feuille de papier et
en dernière chose je vous entendez
parler des de l'anti-reflet sur frame on
constate aussi que les cette couche de
Quantum d'Hot et nodale ont c'est cet
anti-reflet là et donc qui fait qu'on a
vraiment pas de reflet on pourrait faire
la même expérience que Lauren a fait
juste avant
d'autant que c'est nano cristaux offre
plus donc de vision donc on peut se
mettre à gauche ou à droite du
téléviseur et on a une qualité d'image
qui ne va bien là je vois bien je suis
bien pour se mettre un petit film à la
fin du live on devrait voilà donc
maintenant
si tu veux t'acheter un téléviseur chez
Samsung tu as le choix dans toutes les
technologies on trouve 100% des
technologies du marché donc si tu aimes
la marque voilà si tu aimes ce qu'on
fait bah au moins tu peux pas dire ah
bah non j'ai pas de LED j'ai pas de
micro LED j'ai pas de mini LED j'ai pas
de machin etc tout est là voilà et je
crois que tu viens au CES à Las Vegas la
semaine prochaine alors presque la
semaine prochaine donc dès que tu viens
un peu dans le futur
c'est oui dans 15 jours c'est
je serai là-bas le 3 janvier pour être
très précis on va annoncer nos
nouveautés etc et donc tu as invité sur
un événement Samsung
au César et si je te demande de me dire
ce qui va se passer tu me diras rien
j'imagine si je te le dirai dans trois
semaines tu me donnes
je te le dirai dans 3 semaines mais tu
vas voir qu'on va continuer d'innover en
2023 avec encore plus de produits plus
de techno et voilà pour toujours avoir
le plus d'usage pour nos consommateurs
quoi et du design et du design ça c'est
votre truc
et le partenariat avec les frères brûlés
qui a eu des choses de toujours bien
bien léché très joli pour l'intérieur
les frères roulettes c'était justement
dans le produit dans le shérif ce
produit avec un peu le i la team pour la
typographie voilà que nous avons donc je
sais pas si vous le voyez qu'on peut se
mettre en gros plan voilà et bien sûr la
gauche d'Aurélien on a maintenant une
oeuvre en verticale donc c'est un sapin
de Noël voilà normalement c'est beaucoup
plus rapide il faut juste qu'il y ait
pas d'interférence dans votre
télécommande et vous voyez c'est plutôt
sympa et puis après quand vous le
retournez horizontal et ben soit il
prend le plein écran soit vous changez
d'oeuvre c'est vraiment mon cadeau là
on dit que les cadeaux vont toujours au
pied du sapin exactement tac en tout cas
bon merci pour ce troisième coup de cœur
Kevin c'est vrai que pour nous ça a été
une très très grande réussite de lancer
le cul des lettres sur sur 2022 en
complément de l'ensemble de notre linup
on a vraiment un line-up complet avec
l'ensemble de ces technologies et
l'ensemble de ces produits lifestyle on
a vu juste avant donc voilà j'espère
qu'au moins voilà ça t'a plu de les
découvrir cette année je suis très
curieux de savoir ce qui va arriver
l'année prochaine j'ai hâte d'être comme
toi et puis dans le futur
rendez-vous dans trois semaines merci
Kevin Merci à VOUS bonne soirée merci
Kévin merci merci
TV alors qu'on dit Smart TV ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire téléconnecter quand
connecte son téléviseur à Internet
qu'est-ce qui se passe on est quand même
très belle nouveauté cette année et je
vais laisser Marie nous la présenter on
a eu plein de nouveautés cette année je
suis ravie d'être là avec vous et puis
voilà je renforce un peu la team plus
rouge
donc la Smart télé aujourd'hui chez
Samsung c'est vraiment l'offre hyper
complète pourquoi je dis ça parce que
l'année dernière on a interrogé les
consommateurs de Smart télé on leur a
dit est-ce qu'il manque quelque chose et
il nous avait fait une petite liste de
courses petite liste de cadeaux de Noël
sûrement et sur
le top 20 des applications qui nous
avaient citées et ben nous on en a
intégré une bonne dizaine au moins et
les plus grosses sur le top 6 il y en a
5 qui sont arrivés courants de l'année
2022 par exemple les dernières en date
MyTF1 max et 6play aujourd'hui vous avez
vraiment l'offre la plus complète sur
les téléviseurs Samsung mais ce n'est
pas tout parmi les nouveautés qu'on a
également intégrés au courant de l'année
la piscine c'est gaming hub au sein de
ce Gaming up vous avez toutes les
applications de cloud gaming qui était
cité d'ailleurs par les consommateurs
comme l'application Xbox ou twitch par
exemple et ce Gaming up c'est vraiment
une exclusivité Samsung aujourd'hui
quand vous achetez un téléviseur vous
avez accès aux applications qui donnent
accès aux films de Noël par exemple
n'importe lequel et vous avez également
accès à ces applications qui donne accès
au clair gaming donc ça c'est hyper
complet et sur n'importe quelle
téléviseur et sur le jeu freestyle
également vous avez pas de gaming Home
vous avez toutes les applications
également comme la cité Lorraine tout à
l'heure donc j'ai plus besoin de console
si je veux jouer à travers le gaming hub
exactement on peut jouer sur téléviseur
avec une console quand on le branche on
va retrouver directement la petite icône
d'accès direct à sa console sur son
téléviseur au sein de cette univers
gaming qui a été vraiment pensé pour
ceux qui veulent jouer sur téléviseur
vous avez accès examen également à des
applications de streaming musical que
vous pouvez lancer il y a toutes
également un univers de découverte de
contenu des derniers jeux récents des
jeux qui sont poussés par les
applications qui sont présentes dans le
téléviseur donc sur console sur PC bien
entendu ça s'était déjà le cas avant et
aujourd'hui également en Clark gaming
super
et ça c'est surtout le téléviseur Smart
TV 2022 et à venir 2023 et sur les
téléviseurs 2021 les applications de
cloud gaming vont également être
disponibles ok cool ça veut dire que si
j'ai acheté un téléviseur il y a deux
ans je suis tranquille je peux avoir
Claude gaming dessus et en plus on se
parle de téléviseur Smart c'est aussi
des téléviseurs UHD 4K il y a des jeux
en 4K qui arrivent également pour
l'année 2023 c'est cadeau pour Noël et
c'est d'autant plus important que
pendant le covid l'écran de télévision
dans le salon essentiellement est devenu
l'écran préféré du foyer les gens se
sont retrouvés c'est avant on était dans
le multi écran etc et tout le monde
s'est retrouvé autour du téléviseur et
un téléviseur pour tout le monde c'est
une source d'entertainment et ça tu
regardes la télévision ou tu regardes de
la VOD et bien maintenant ce n'est plus
que ça maintenant tu peux jouer avec ton
téléviseur ou autour de ton téléviseur
voilà en famille plusieurs voilà tu
trouves tous les usages sont cool c'est
super parce que pour les personnes qui
effectivement n'ont pas de console ou
non pas forcément les moyens de réussir
dans une dans une console dernière
génération avec les solutions de stock
gaming alors effectivement il y a
toujours un petit abonnement à prendre
derrière mais pour autant tu as juste à
avoir des manettes ta télé et en avant
quoi exactement c'est chouette on a
perdu une manette
c'est compatible avec la quasi-totalité
des manettes du marché et c'est parti en
filaire en Bluetooth toutes les
fonctionnalités sont là pour faciliter
justement le jeu sur Télé trop chouette
il y a un troisième pont de la Smart qui
est aussi important c'est notre notre
ambiante mode donc c'est à dire un peu
comme on a vu sur le frime c'est à dire
de d'essayer d'effacer l'écran noir que
tu as sur ton mur ou sur ta télé tu as
des images des photos même bientôt du
metaves qui en sont en train d'arriver
sur notre collection dans le téléviseur
ou même tu peux plugin clé USB et mettre
et aujourd'hui quand tu mets en veille
et ben tu as justement ton écran qui
n'est plus un écran noir qui devient une
sorte de tableau mais tu as pas l'effet
quand même
tableau que l'on a avec le capteur de
luminosité ou le capteur de présence que
tu as sur un frame c'est un peu
différent mais on l'a et donc je trouve
que c'est important parce que dans ton
chat il y a pas mal de commentaires
notamment sur la consommation d'énergie
et je sais pas tu as vu
juste pour vous dire qu'aujourd'hui avec
le gaming pass on a plus besoin de
consoles donc en fait quand tu joues tu
as pas besoin de rebrancher d'accord des
des devices tu sais aussi que sur nos
téléviseurs on a des applications de des
box télé qu'on arrive à dématérialiser
si tu prends un abonnement par exemple
Bouygues Telecom tu as plus besoin de
box TV elle est intégrée dans ton
téléviseur donc tu n'as plus besoin de
boxe c'est moins anxiogène pour brancher
tous les câbles mais surtout ça fait
beaucoup moins de câbles ça libère de
l'espace à la maison ça c'est vachement
chouette et c'est pour le ménage et ça
consomme moins ce que tu as une box en
moins exactement donc ça répond à une
personne à quelques personnes de ton
chat donc ça c'est vachement cool
d'avoir effectivement c'est ces
applications opérateur dedans parce que
je suis tout le temps en train de
m'embêter avec la petite chiffolette
anti-poussière et ça voilà donc moi
j'aime bien faire place Neuve et c'est
bien de tout avoir dans un seul et même
appareil et l'accès facilité une seule
télécommande au même endroit elles sont
déjà en plus prêt téléchargées comme
énormément de de d'applications
pertinentes pour le consommateur donc on
accède directement soit ABtv plus
l'application Bouygues Telecom oki ou
Orange TV sur son téléviseur Samsung on
a le choix
et c'est pour ça ce coup de cœur il est
sympa pour nous parce qu'en fait quand
tu vas en magasin tout le monde se dit
ah ma Smart TV c'est pareil pour tout le
monde ouais j'ai Netflix et Disney plus
c'est YouTube en fait on arrive avec ces
trois pans qu'on vient de vous présenter
d'avoir une différenciation de personnes
donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal les
opérateurs le gaming le mode ambiance
j'irai même quelques applications ou par
exemple MyTF1 on est les premiers à
l'avoir on a été parmi les premiers
6play également et aujourd'hui quand on
pose la question qu'on se pose qui
manque quelque chose dans les téléviseur
Smart Samsung ils sont beaucoup moins
nombreux que l'année dernière à répondre
oui manque un truc tu verras la
prochaine vidéo
live je sais pas qui fera sur les
diviseurs 2023 il va encore voilà il va
souligner l'exclusivité la
différenciation de Samsung sur la soirée
mais c'est pas mal c'est l'usage ouais
mais c'est vachement important parce
qu'effectivement ça qu'on parle beaucoup
de produits alors pour autant il y a
plein de nouvelles et c'est génial sur
les qualités d'image sur les dalles
c'est vrai que c'est top mais
l'expérience logicielle elle est
extrêmement importante parce que on va
passer plus de temps en naviguer à avoir
un accès rapide ou évident à ces
applications et c'est effectivement là
où le service rendu est aussi
extrêmement fort donc c'est chouette
d'avoir une très très belle expérience
là-dessus et d'avoir effectivement une
offre qui est très complète et pour le
coup ça a le choix surtout avec des
services de qualité de belle qualité
d'image parce que c'est la source
justement pour profiter au mieux de son
écran 4K c'est une belle qualité de son
également je fais une petite transition
avec la personne juste après voilà mais
c'est hyper important parce que quand on
regarde un film il y a pas que l'image
il y a aussi le son et les applications
de Smart TV donnent accès à du super
qualité de son aussi dans leur contenu
la variété le choix et ça c'est hyper
important on peut accéder aux chaînes en
direct ou en replay avec justement les
applications opérateurs entre autres
choses et tout ça hyper facilement trop
chouette merci beaucoup Marie merci
quatrième coup de cœur on a juste une
question dans le chat c'est psycho qui
nous demande la box dans la TV avec
n'importe quelle opérateur tous les
opérateurs ou pas question donc
effectivement j'ai cité nous avons BTV
plus de Bouygues Telecom ok by free donc
de Free et Orange TV ok merci à vous
merci Marie
donc comme l'a dit Marie un téléviseur
sans barre de son c'est bien mais ça
pourrait être mieux si tu arrives à
allier une barre de son et pour en
parler et bien j'appelle anit Anita
bonjour salut comment ça va bien ça va
bien
donc tu vas nous parler de quoi
on a parlé de téléviseur donc on va
parler de barre de son comme Monsieur
greu à évoqué tout à l'heure au début du
live je parlais de la nouvelle barre de
son essuie son
donc c'est la barre de son ultra fine
qu'on a lancé en avril et comme vous
pouvez le remarquer sa spécificité c'est
qu'elle est vraiment fine donc elle fait
que 3,8 cm de hauteur
c'est tout fin c'est puissant même si
c'est fin c'est puissant même si c'est
fin ça t'étonne
c'est marqué dans le dans le chat c'est
pas parce qu'elle est fine qu'elle n'est
pas puissante parce qu'elle a 10 au par
là donc elle est elle a des
haut-parleurs verticaux et vous avez la
nouvelle technologie donc la Dolby Atmos
s'enfile je sais pas si tu es au courant
samsung a lancé pour la première fois le
Dolby Atmos sans fil parce que jusqu'à
maintenant il fallait avoir un câble
HDMI pour connecter la barre de son
téléviseur maintenant tu en as plus
besoin
[Rires]
tu veux vraiment l'intégration avec un
frame et que tu mets une Marie-Louise
que tu veux un cadre blanc puisque tu
pues le culmuser avec un cadre blanc une
barre de son comme ça complètement épuré
sans fil avec juste ton cas
d'alimentation ça fait quand même le job
donc c'est assez sympa dans
l'intégration totale
aussi qui sont incluses dans le
packaging donc tu peux l'accrocher
facilement au mur c'est hyper rapide
c'est la terre opérabilité entre ton
téléviseur et ta barre de son tu sais
qu'aujourd'hui quand tu regardes ta télé
tu as tes haut-parleurs de ton
téléviseur voilà puis il y a des il y a
des personnes qui disent oui mais c'est
bien mais plus l'écran est fin plus tu
colles contre le mur moins tentant tu as
moins de caisse de résonance ce qui est
un peu vrai c'est pour ça qu'on
travaille avec beaucoup plus de parieurs
derrière le téléviseur et quand tu
achètes une barre de son pour le faire
et bah ça coupe les haut-parleurs de ton
téléviseur quel que soit la marque ou
quel que soit la techno
donc avec notre technologie
QY symphonie
qui s'appelle cul symphonie donc c'est
sur les séries
SSQ oui
en fait c'est une technologie
propriétaire Samsung et en fait on
arrive à compléter le haut-parleur enfin
de comment on appelle ça synchroniser
le son de ta barre de son avec les
haut-parleurs de ton téléviseur donc en
fait ça amplifie ton son et ça ne coupe
pas une source ça c'est vachement bien
c'est un truc de dingue non mais
franchement voilà c'est pour ça que
c'est un coup de cœur parce que en
dehors du design du produit ça cette
technocus symphonie qui amplifie ton son
donc les mecs quand il l'écoute c'est
waouh ouais voilà c'est ça exactement
on a vendu beaucoup sur la fin d'année
justement et les gens qui ont testé
cette barre de son étaient assez conquis
parce que justement il s'attendait pas à
escabulation sur aussi puissante et on a
de très bon avis sur le site parce que
justement ils sont assez contents de
l'arracha ok c'est génial c'est vrai
qu'elle est belle puissante le fait de
pouvoir l'avoir en plus qui fonctionne
en synchro avec le son de la télé
c'est c'est très très chouette
alors à tester
voilà on a quelques quelques questions
quelques questions notamment sur le
système Android pourquoi on n'a pas un
système Android on a un système Tyson
c'est un format propriétaire parce qu'on
estime que aujourd'hui ce format Tyson
est vraiment adapté à au streaming et
justement à pouvoir recevoir de
l'entertainment donc d'avoir une
plateforme plus agnostique plus
généraliste comme comme Android même si
nos téléphones se sont Android voilà
c'est l'addition de Samsung et ça permet
d'avoir beaucoup d'évolution et beaucoup
de transformation c'est pour ça qu'on
est un peu en avance de phase avec la
plateforme Android propose plus de
choses que c'est ça je me trompe pas
trop ah bah oui oui Non Non mais Tyson
ça marche moi c'est une expérience que
j'ai connu effectivement il y a
longtemps parce que je m'intéresse
depuis longtemps à la tech et
l'expérience Tyson elle marche vraiment
bien et pour l'avoir tester sur
différents modèles à chaque fois je
trouve que c'est clair c'est simple tu
tires très facilement et c'est
fonctionnel donc après c'est ça dépendra
de chaque utilisateur parce que il y a
des gens qui vont être habitués à avoir
un Google TV qui vont se dire ah j'ai
pas mes habitudes bon il faut essayer il
faut essayer une fois qu'on rentre
dedans c'est vrai que ça fonctionne
super bien
voilà on a passé en revue nos cinq coups
de cœur déjà voilà cinq coups de cœur et
donc justement quel est ton coup de
coeur parmi ces cinq toi ou peut-être
qu'on en a oublié un que toi tu gardes
en tête sur les produits télé Samsung
sur l'ensemble de notre gamme quel est
le produit pour toi en 2022 dans tous
les rendez-vous que tu as fait avec
Samsung qui quel produit qui t'a le plus
marqué alors moi le produit qui m'a le
plus surpris
c'est compliqué de pas être coup de cœur
tu vois mes produits qui m'a le plus
surpris qui était un peu un peu
différent c'est effectivement the
freestyle parce que c'est l'idée
d'emmener ton image partout avec toi
alors ça va pas forcément être fait pour
tout le monde ça va pas être fait pour
tous les usages mais je trouve ça
chouette de pouvoir se dire allez je
pars par exemple demain en famille on se
prend une petite loque et comme tu le
disais des fois la télé tu étais sûr de
rien tu l'emmènes avec toi tu pars en
camping et ça c'est aussi un truc qui
est marrant et c'est ce que j'avais vu
aussi ces dernières sur votre stand
c'est que tu pars en camping bah tu peux
te projeter dans l'attente tu vas pas
emmener une télé dans une tente tu vois
les têtes tu vas pas le faire ou tu te
fais un truc avec des potes un peu à
l'arrache bah tu peux te mettre un film
il y a un petit bout de mur tac le soir
tu as envie de te faire plaisir
tu te le mets tu projettes
tu te mets le film tu es détendu ça
c'est chouette donc ça c'est super cool
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a surpris alors
après il y a plein de choses j'ai trouvé
ça génial aussi que cette année vous
mettiez la la Dalmat parce que une fois
de plus ça vient vraiment apporter pas
mal de pas mal de pas mal de
possibilités puis par rapport à des gens
qui une fois de plus on défend un peu
trop de de lumière parasites chez eux là
ça résout le problème donc ça ça me
plaît et puis bon après euh ce que tu
veux dire bref tous les produits mais
bon voilà en fait tes cinq coups de cœur
sont des coups de cœur mais par contre
chez toi donc la question que tu as posé
puisque maintenant il faut revenir au
tirage au sort je te laisse la main et
ben comme je vous le disais en début de
live on Samsung m'a dit tiens Aurel on
voudrait te proposer de faire gagner à
ta communauté un freestyle donc du coup
on va faire ça très simplement tu vas
mettre sur Twitter un petit message tu
vas dire ok répondez juste et dites-nous
quel est votre produit préféré il y a
pas de mauvaise réponse clair c'était
histoire de prendre un peu de
température et c'est super intéressant
c'est plein de bons enseignements donc
le tirage au sort a été fait par une
main innocente et la personne qui a
gagné il y a le nom qui apparaît qui va
paraître là quelque part voilà BIM PAF
cinépi cinéphy sur Twitter alors je l'ai
pas encore écrit je vais lui envoyer un
petit message parce que je voulais
garder la l'effet de surprise donc je
vais lui envoyer un petit message tout à
l'heure sur Twitter félicitations en
tout cas parce qu'effectivement tu
repars avec un freestyle et tu vas
pouvoir regarder tes contenus partout où
tu sois voilà en mobilité ça c'est
chouette ben écoute on est ravi parce
que moi ça fera un heureux et puis comme
tu le dis c'est un produit surprenant
qui est tout à fait d'actualité pour
cette fin d'année quand il va falloir
partir en famille voilà et regardez du
contenu différemment c'est l'objectif et
puis accessoire qui me fait marrer je le
vois
c'est une mousqueton à quel moment tu
dis et c'est ça qui est marrant en fait
il est évident que les gens n'ont pas le
mettre à la ceinture ou tu vas pas
l'accrocher ton sac à dos mais l'idée là
la pensée est là c'est la mobilité tac
je le mets hop et on part parler de
camping on s'est dit tiens on ta
mousqueton et ben bravo bien vu c'est
marrant quoi c'est dans l'ADN du truc
donc ça c'est chouette en tout cas rien
merci beaucoup encore une fois de nous
avoir accompagné ce soir pour ce live
d'avoir clôturé cette première saison tu
as été le premier était le dernier et
donc c'était bien de repasser avec toi
en revue tout ce qu'on a fait cette
année c'est chouette je suis content de
faire ça avec vous ce serait chouette
d'avoir débuté avec vous d'avoir vu
cette nouvelle expérience qui se passait
de votre côté sur mon ami parler avant
que ça se fasse et c'est pas évident
quand on sort dans des projets comme ça
parce que toi c'est pas ton job à la
base donc devenir prendre le lead sur
une émission comme ça c'est une
expérience qui est qui est chouette donc
je suis contente d'avoir vous avoir
accompagné au début puis d'être là pour
plus de Noël avec Snoopy voilà comme ça
c'est cool merci encore à toi merci à ta
communauté d'avoir été dynamique à
travers le chat de continuer de te
suivre parce que comme tu l'as dit on va
se voir au CES à Las Vegas on va devoir
plusieurs fois en 2023 avec toutes les
nouveautés donc tu vas tester tu vas
donner ton avis franc et direct et
dynamique bien et nous c'est ce qu'on
aime donc merci encore je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année un
Joyeux Noël prenez soin de vous et puis
on se retrouve l'année prochaine sous un
format peut-être encore différent mais
on va continuer à garder le contact
merci beaucoup bonne fête à bientôt à
tous Ciao
[Musique]